schöner Mist Freunde da denkt man das
zarte pflänzchenwirtschaft wächst
langsam wieder und plötzlich ist fünf
Minuten vor Bankenkrise und wir stehen
am Beginn des handelskriegs USA gegen
China heißt es jetzt überall mit dem
kleinen Deutschland in der Rolle des
scheidungskinds ah fiese Zwickmühle
wirklich ganz fiese Zwickmühle wirklich
washington will Peking von modernen
Halbleitern abschneiden und
technologisch isolieren aber wenn wir da
mitmachen sind die Chinesen bestimmt
sauer und kaufen keine S-Klasse mehr
Präsident ist quasi unser Premium
goldkunde gerade in Peking wiedergewählt
mit 100% der stimmt ist ein ganz okay
das Ergebnis
3000 Hand verlesene Delegierte sind
zusammengekommen zum Nationalen
Volkskongress jeder von ihnen hat eine
Teetasse vor sich außer Präsident
heating der hat zwei ein Zufall ist das
offenbar nicht sondern eine Macht
Demonstration
ist das so meine Damen und Herren
zu Hause habe ich sogar eine Kanne stell
dir das mal vor
Ski sagt der Westen verfolgt die
Einkreisung und Unterdrückung Chinas und
ich sag mal wenn sich eine auskennt mit
Unterdrückung
Problem China zu sehr in die Ecke
drängen hilft nur Putin vor allem aber
und das ist die entscheidende Frage
können wir es uns überhaupt leisten
diesen Mangel zu verärgern sie müssen
sich klar machen nur vier deutsche
Konzerne BMW Mercedes VW und BASF nur
die 4 stehen für rund ein Drittel der
europäischen Direktinvestitionen in
China verstehen sie nicht Europa ist
abhängig von denen hauptsächlich wir das
Quartet hier macht sich immer
erpressbarer und uns alle als
Gesellschaft gleich mit hier Drogen mal
in nett von der sagt deutsche
Unternehmen leisten großartiges in China
zum Wohle der chinesischen Verbraucher
und der deutschen Geschäftsinteressen
ich hoffe dass die so weitergeht
Lieferketten können kaputt gehen
wäre doch total schade wenn eure schönen
Energiewende was passiert oder ja
80% der Solarmodule kommen aus China und
da waren wie immer Weltmarktführer
genauso tief gepennt haben wir bei
Batterien Windkraft Generatoren werden
Magneten Seltene Erden aus China
brauchen bei Computerchips kurz gesagt
bei der Zukunft haben wir gepennt
gepennt doch jetzt Freunde
irgendwie kann das Tragen oder doch
jetzt rettet uns die Planwirtschaft die
EU-Kommission Meldung von heute plant
ein fettes subventionspaket damit im
Jahr 2030 40 Prozent dieser sensiblen
Produkte in Europa hergestellt werden
ein siebenjahresplan der späte Sieg der
DDR ja
so da wir nach meiner Uhr aber erst 2023
haben kann vor allem Deutschland nur
noch beten dass China nicht allzu weit
in Taiwan einmarschiert die USA drohen
derweil mit einem Komplettverbot der
chinesischen App tiktok ja darf auch auf
Diensthandys deutscher Ministerien seit
einiger Zeit nicht mehr installiert sein
klar privat nutzen unsere Politiker
natürlich weiter tiktok und das ist eine
wunderbare Vorstellung dass da
chinesische Geheimdienst Leute die
tiktok Filme von Markus Söder gucken
müssen ich bin sowieso ein Fan von Hunde
sind so treue loyale Tiere zu viel Spaß
mit ihnen und mal ganz so schweigen von
den Videos von Philipp am Tor also im
Bundestag gibt's so Currywurst im
Bundestag gibt's keinen Döner ich es
aber tatsächlich ab und an durchaus
gerne mal ein und man hat ja glaube
jeder hat so sein lieblingstöne kurz
gesagt das wünscht man echt keine meine
Damen und Herren
nicht mal den chinesischen Geheimdienst
ja stimmt doch
tiktok erhältlich in ihrem App hörstore
meine Damen und Herren inzwischen so
heißt es erwegt die Bundesregierung ein
Verbot chinesischer Komponenten im
Deutschen 5g-netz ja bisschen spät
vielleicht aber ich sag mal der gute
Wille zählt und so viel China Technik
wird ja wohl nicht drin sein oder
59% aller bisher verbauten Teile im
deutschen Funk Zugangsnetz sind von
chinesischen Unternehmen oh Sekunde ich
rechne das mal kurz für Sie nach
5g -
59% macht 3G Scheiße
oh so eine Scheiße ja vielleicht können
wir ja wenigstens die Funkmasten als
Windräder weiter nutzen in einigen
Punkten ist Deutschland wenn man darüber
nachdenkt wirklich erschreckend naiv
alleine an unseren Bahnhöfen Behörden
und Flughäfen kritische Infrastruktur
kommen 78.000 Überwachungskameras aus
China zum Einsatz
und das Drehmaterial läuft habe ich
gehört im chinesischen TV dann als
Comedy-Sendung Thymian Song hallo und
mihao bei Deutschland Tag und Nacht der
Comedy Reality-Show chinesische Kameras
Filmen das lustige Leben der deutschen
guck mal sie warten immer wieder auf
Züge obwohl sie längst wissen sollten
dass nie einer kommt
dich über Deutsche die in der Bahn ein
Buch lesen weil es kein Internet gibt
vor allem aber über den niedlichen
Minister der seine Energiewende bald
ohne unsere Solarzellen hinkriegen muss
ja wirklich der Typ da ist Minister
Deutschland Tag und Nacht wie doof sind
die denn
[Applaus]
gute Frage gute Frage
es ist ja so und das betrifft uns alle
nicht nur die Politik über Jahrzehnte
haben wir es uns als eine Art XXL
Schweiz gemütlich gemacht Hauptsache
Geschäfte mit allen jetzt heißt es
plötzlich erwachsen werden und mehr für
Sicherheit tun aktuelles Beispiel wo wir
gerade beim Abhören sind der BND also
unser Bundesnachrichtendienst so der hat
es leider nicht geschafft der hat es
nicht geschafft den Einmarsch Putins in
Ukraine vorherzusagen im Gegensatz zu
fast allen anderen Diensten was man
daran erkennt dass der BND-Chef Bruno
Karl am Tag der Inversion zufällig
selber in Kiefer
der muss in einer waghalsigen Aktion
evakuiert werden selbst unsere Minister
wurden vor Kriegsbeginn nicht von BND
sondern von den Amis informiert für mich
war es so dass ich am Vorabend des
Krieges noch eine amerikanische
Ministerkollegin zu Besuch hatte beim
Rausgehen hat nicht die amerikanische
Botschaft die sie begleitet hat
mit Informationen versorgt die gesagt
haben heute Nacht geht's los ja und
Annalena baerbock hat es dann von Dunja
Hayali im Frühstücksfernsehen erfahren
ne
meine Güte kurz danach fliegt beim BND
auch noch ein russischer Spion auf nach
Überraschung Hinweisen anderer
Geheimdienste Carsten l hatte Zugang zu
sensibelsten Informationen und konnte
die offenbar problemlos rausschmuggeln
außerdem gab es seit Jahren Hinweise auf
eine rechtsradikale Gesinnung
auf der anderen Seite meine was heißt
schon Hinweise laut einem Bericht des
SPIEGEL soll im bmd-kollegen Kreis
sinngemäß davon gesprochen haben er
würde Asylbewerber am liebsten
standrechtlich erschießen okay das ist
ein Hinweis ja
Karsten L hat trotzdem alle
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen überstanden und
der BND hat sich bis auf die Knochen
blamiert dabei ist das mit 6.500
Mitarbeitern unser größter Geheimdienst
mich hat mal live in die Berliner
Zentrale zu Martin Klempner Leiter der
Auslandsaufklärung erklärt nur der excia
ey Mann John Center seit Zitat arrogant
unfähig und vollkommen nutzlos
das ist eine Unverschämtheit herbecke
wir sind überhaupt nicht arrogant die
blöden Amis ja die haben den zehnfachen
Etat und super moderne Technik und was
haben wir hier diese Kollegin versucht
rauszufinden wann Putin in Moldau
einmarschiert gibt's was neues
ist eine ganz neue Technik sonst liest
sie aus Eingeweiden von Katzen wir
dürfen ja nichts seit einem Urteil aus
Karlsruhe gelten für Ausländer die wir
im Ausland ausspionieren die deutschen
Grundrechte
Dieter
zu schweigen verstehe aber woher kommen
denn dann eure Informationen
wir uns aus dem Fernsehen das hier das
ist einer meiner besten Agenten ja der
schaut den ganzen Tag Phoenix und dass
sie da sind Chef immer im Schwarzen Meer
ist Nami Drohne mit einem Russen Jet
zusammengedeckt offene Sache ja Youtube
Wissen halten Sie mich weiter auf dem
laufenden nach dem Kalten Krieg haben
wir 15 Jahre lang keine fremden
Geheimdienste mehr ausspioniert weil
weil
ich jetzt auch nicht aber jetzt kommen
wir so langsam wieder rein
wenn du sollst doch nur Phoenix gucken
voll langweilig
ich bin in einer halben Stunde
ach ja das habe ich ganz vergessen das
ist der Sascha den habe ich neulich auf
Malle kennengelernt ja und da habe ich
ihm und seiner Frau versprochen sie
könnten sich mal unser Büro angucken ach
mensch das ist ja nett ja kommen Sie
rein fühlt sich ganz viel zu Hause war
guck mal
auf jeden Fall das ist ja ein ulkiger
Dialekt woher kommt er denn ich meine
Thüringen Thüringen wunderbar
wie war die Frage ich habe gar keine
Frage mehr Martin Klempner und Dennis
knossalla meine Damen und Herren vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
eine weitere Erfolgsgeschichte so meine
Damen und jetzt wird's ernst sechste
Stunde Chemie bei Herrn welke Thema pfas
gesprochen hast bekannt aus dem Roland
Kaiser Hit 7 Fässer weinen können uns
nicht gefährlich sein wir reden hier
über Peer und polyurrierte
alkoholverbindungen die sind drin in
alle möglichen z.B in unseren Radfahren
ja und zwar wegen ihrer
ausgeprägten antihaft Eigenschaften
tatsächlich finden sich fast garantiert
auch in Ihrer Nähe hier nach neuesten
Recherchen 1.500 toxisch belastete Orte
davon 300 sogar stark belastet wenn du
das gesehen kaum fifas in Brandenburg
der erste echte Grund dahin zu ziehen
ist nur Spaß
es gibt keinen Grund nach Brandenburg zu
ziehen
leider reden wir hier von Chemikalien
die sich geschätzte tausend Jahre im
Boden anreichern wie verstehen im
Verdacht unter anderem krebserregend zu
sein und unfruchtbar zu machen ja
Stichwort Spermienqualität und quasi ein
direkter Angriff auf unsere hodenschätze
wenn Sie verstehen was ich meine
einige fifas sind nachgewiesen giftig
für die allermeisten fehlen aber Daten
Problem jede der rund 10.000 Substanzen
einzeln zu prüfen die Zeit haben wir gar
nicht denn das Zeug findet etwa über
Kläranlagen längst den Weg ins
Grundwasser inzwischen sind auch
landwirtschaftliche Nutzflächen
betroffen so dass Bauern da fast nichts
mehr anbauen können weil man fürs
verseuchte Erde austauschen viel zu tief
buddeln müsste wie hier in Rastatt zum
Beispiel
Sanierungsmaßnahmen sind bei diese
Dimensionen eigentlich gar nicht
umsetzbar
also
fange jetzt mal klein an zwei Milliarden
Schnäppchen oder zwei Milliarden wenn du
das als Brauer wieder rauskriegen willst
kostet das Schälchen Erdbeeren schnell
mal 5000 Euro von der Belastung für
unsere Gewässer mal ganz zu schweigen
Freunde es muss was passieren
wirklich
ja der ist nur gemalt
Deutschland Dänemark Norwegen Schweden
und die Niederlande schlagen jetzt vor
alle piefers EU weit zu verbieten
seitdem können sich denken sind die
chemie-lobby ist natürlich auf dem
kriegsfahrt der Verband der
kochgeschirrhersteller z.B wollte
neulich beweisen wie ungefährlich so
antihaft von sind weil es dafür gar
keine Quellen gab haben die sich auf
eine Studie berufen und deren Aussagen
dabei mal eben ins komplette Gegenteil
verkehrt der Verband sagt man habe eben
nur einen Sachverhalt zitiert aber hätte
man die Hauptaussage der Studie nicht
auch nennen müssen
also ich kenne keine Firma die sagt
bitte kauft mein Produkt nicht
ja ich kann aber auch keinen Kunden der
sagt bitte lügt mich an
was ist denn für eine Logik leider gibt
es immer noch keine einheitlichen
Messverfahren und Grenzwerte für piefers
dabei ist vieles längst bekannt zum
Beispiel dass die Substanzen in
Feuerwehr Löschschaum enthalten sind
unter anderem
ein ernstes Problem dass wir viel zu
lange ignoriert haben wieder mal zum
Schaden unserer Kinder und Enkel muss
man den jetzt mal schonend und
kindgerecht beibringen herzlich
Willkommen zu
[Musik]
Löwenzahn der auf griefers verseuchtem
Boden wächst mit Petra unlustig
hallo Kinder
na habt ihr langsam die Schnauze voll
von dem was euch Mama und Papa so
hinterlassen
Klimawandel Schuldenberge und wegen der
Bankenkrise die nächste Woche richtig
losgeht ist euer ganzes Taschengeld weg
und ihr könnt euch nie wieder ein
Überraschungsei kaufen und eure
Eltern keine Playstation sondern noch
als Eisenbahn
er möchte euch lieber anlügen damit wir
alle zusammen weiterleben in der
Prinzessin lillifestraße im
gummibärenland ihr solltet Angst haben
Kinder vor allem wegen piefers
das sind sogenannte ewige Chemikalien
die Reichen sich ewig im Boden an ewig
kennt ihr ne nein
wisst ihr noch als eure Eltern euch
letzten November gezwungen haben mit
ihnen wetten das zu gucken
moderiert von dem Opa mit der blonden
Perücke
das fühlte sich ewig an war aber nur
sehr langweilig und nicht sehr giftig
sorry können wir jetzt vielleicht doch
noch mal eine positive Note reinbringen
geht das leider nein auch wenn die EU
ein Verbot aller pieferste plant
Industrie und Lobby sind den Lichtjahre
voraus Beispiel eine andere ewige
Chemikalien namens PFOA ist ja schon
seit 2020 verboten wegen dem Krebs und
so die foa wurde in der EU inzwischen
verboten und sofort wurde die Industrie
innovativ und ersetzt in die Substanz
mit anderen piefers neuer Name ähnliche
Aufbau Wissenschaft und Politik kommen
nicht hinterher die Liste der Kiefers
wird immer länger
und das
hört wenn wir durch Pieper alle unfrucht
Bar sind und keine
Kinder kriegen Angst und weil einige von
euch süßen jetzt denken na und dann
kaufe ich eben keine Sachen mehr drin
sind oder pofase verrate ich euch jetzt
mal welche Produkte das betrifft
wirklich jetzt Zahnseide Klopapier
Coffee to go Becher Bettwäsche antihaft
von Regenjacken Zelte und genießen Pizza
Kartons Burger Papier okay jetzt wird
gruselig Outdoor-Schuhe Gesicht
Tischdecken Polstermöbel Elektrogeräte
und jetzt schauen wir aus
Raclette Pfännchen Backpapier
Solarzellen Computerchips
aber jetzt
Skiwachs Druckfarbe feuerlöscherschaum
Klebeetiketten
[Applaus]
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an